supercomputers
today our dream team is checking out how
we can supersize computing power
[Music]
to calculate the number of raindrops
until the end of my holidays i'll need
to
supercomputers can process mind-boggling
amounts of data
they'll soon reach the computing power
of all mobile phones across the eu taken
together hey my phone that's 10 to the
power of 18 operations per seconds
the so-called exascale
what exactly do we need that for uh
don't look at me i don't have the answer
the average computer does just fine for
everyday data crunching
just lost five percent of my followers
after posting this but for certain tasks
we'll need to think big
very big oh my god these include
tackling challenges such as monitoring
climate change and forecasting severe
weather conditions oh wow thanks because
my calculator's flooded improving cyber
security
stop hacking my password and even
deciphering the human brain well it was
your cat's name
recently european supercomputers have
helped to search for and test cures for
covid19
eight more supercomputer centers will
host three pre-exascale and five
petascale supercomputers that will
enable the eu to become a global leader
in supercomputing
one day supercomputers will even be able
to map and recreate your own digital
virtual dna twin
i could test medical treatments on my
twin or see if this new diet works
[Music]